hello screen junkies I'm Dan Moreau host
of Summer Movie report on screen junkies
plus and this is the screen junkie
spoiler review of x-men apocalypse if
you want to read my non-spoiler thoughts
you can check out my review live right
now on screen junkies comso final
warning if you do not want to get
spoiled on x-men apocalypse tune out now
otherwise let's get to the review
he always had four principal followers
disciples protectors he would imbue with
powers like the Four Horsemen of the
Apocalypse this guy looks like he really
wants to cause some kind of apocalypse
x-men apocalypse is either the ninth the
sixth or the third film in the x-men
franchise depending on how you decide to
count it and that's just one indication
of how confused and messed up this
franchises timeline has gotten excellent
Apocalypse is set ten years after Days
of Future past which was itself set ten
years after x-men first class which
means it's been 20 years since we first
met James McAvoy Michael Fassbender
Nicholas Hoult and all of these new
x-men which also makes me wonder what
kind of mutant gene these x-men have
against aging x-men producers please
stop with the time jumps I don't need
the next x-men movie to be set in 1993
where you make some kind of Jurassic
Park reference it's not needed just make
the movies this time the x-men are
fighting the super villain apocalypse
who is so named because he wants to
cause an apocalypse get it once again we
have the evil villain who wants to
destroy the world to purify the world a
lot like we saw in age of Ultron last
summer and a lot like we've seen in so
many other countless superhero movies
every single shot of the destruction
that you've seen in the trailers is in
the movies and that's it this movie is
called x-men apocalypse and they had a
chance to really bring something big and
unexpected and new to the table and it's
the same thing that you've seen so many
times before it's really kind of just an
annoyance it should have been called
x-men annoyance because that's all
Apocalypse really is at the end of the
day and the sad thing is that this movie
had a great set up that really had me
engaged for the first 45 minutes of the
film I really liked what they did with
apocalypses backstory I think they set
him up as a really interesting villain I
liked the opening in ancient Egypt and I
liked what they did with
magnito one of my big qualms going into
the movie is why would magneto kind of
change sides depending on where we've
seen him in this franchise and become
one of the Four Horsemen of the
Apocalypse that Apocalypse found him at
the lowest moment in his life that
worked for me mainly because of Michael
Fassbender and his performance so for
the first 45 minutes of this movie I was
digging it I was really into it and then
the destruction starts and everything is
rote it's by the numbers it's like they
started writing 1/3 of an interesting
movie and then went and then some stuff
happens and then the end and one of the
movies big problems is that it is at
times completely tone-deaf the biggest
example of the tone-deaf nature of this
movie comes with the Quicksilver scene
now it was such a surprise and a delight
in Days of Future past it was probably
the best scene in that movie and here
it's like Bryan Singer said well people
liked it in this movie so let's do it
again and bigger in this movie but he
put it in the worst possible place when
it comes at the destruction of Xavier
z-man's and it just fell flat for me
because it was put in the wrong place in
the movie and that's so much of what
this movie was it was things just kind
of put in because they felt like they
were requirements without any real
regard to the tone or where it fit into
the movie and that's why this movie
feels so disjointed and disappointing to
me something else that really annoyed me
about this movie was an overabundance of
just paying lip service to the comics
and to the lore of the x-men now one of
the big selling points of this movie was
that storm and psylocke and Angel were
going to be big parts of the movie they
were going to be three of apocalypses
four horsemen and they were three of the
most disappointing parts of the movie
there was absolutely no reason for them
to be those characters they weren't
giving anything special to do they
weren't giving any character development
to have they may as well have been
henchman one two and three angel is
dispatched basically off-camera with one
fleeting mention this is one of the five
founding members of the x-men in the
comics an archangel is probably the most
pivotal figure in the comic books to the
apocalypse story and I'm not saying that
you have to be completely slavish and
faithful to the storyline in the comm
this is a movie and it should stand on
its own but it's the fact that they took
these characters that means so much to
x-men fans gave them generic
interchangeable roles and then just kind
of shuffled them off screen without any
ceremony psylocke literally just kind of
walks out of the movie this is also the
case with Jubilee who's being featured
in the viral marketing for this movie
and another big thing that they're
pushing is like Jubilee is finally going
to get her shot in x-men apocalypse I
don't think they use her name once if
they do they certainly don't use it
twice and not one time does she use her
mutant powers does she do anything other
than go to the mall which we've already
seen she did that in the x-men animated
series and get knocked unconscious
that's it when you put so much
anticipation to the appearance of these
characters and then do nothing with them
it seems like a misstep to me because
you've set people up to expect so much
more now let's talk Wolverine real quick
or reveal that I wish they'd save for
the movie and not put in the third
trailer because I intentionally didn't
want to know if Wolverine was in this
movie but he is indeed except he's
Weapon X and it is so cool to see the
Weapon X Wolverine on screen and a movie
other than x-men origins Wolverine which
was an absolute abomination and yes the
action scene with Weapon X in the bunker
is ten times better than any second any
bit of X and origins Wolverine it's
maybe the best Wolverine action sequence
ever put to film in any of the other
movies and it is completely unnecessary
to this particular movie yes it's cool
yes viewed on its own it is a great
Wolverine action sequence but it is only
there in service to the later movies and
that's another problem that I have with
this movie is even the fight against
apocalypse seems like it is done to set
up a Phoenix storyline later on nothing
in this movie has any consequence has
any weight it has an elastic impact
everybody ends this movie in exactly the
same spot where they began and that's my
biggest problem with x-men apocalypse is
it a terrible movie no it's not a
terrible movie but it is completely
empty it has no lasting meaning or
impact it doesn't tell us or show us
anything new it doesn't bring anything
new to the franchise it's almost like
this movie could be wiped away and it
wouldn't change a thing and the x-men
mythology and that's just not good
enough these days but despite these
disappointments they're worse
things that I absolutely liked first of
all Michael Fassbender is a great actor
and he continues to really bring it in
his performances magneto particularly in
the first hour of the film I like how
his magneto is conflicted I just wish
that the movie would do more with that
conflict other than always bringing him
full circle back around to being friends
with Xavier secondly taken apart from
the movie and apart from the context the
Quicksilver sequence and the Wolverine
sequence are both really strong great
action sequences they're going to make
great standalone YouTube clips one day
my problem is that their placement in
the movie doesn't make any sense and
they both stop the movie dead in its
tracks to get these obligatory
characters incorporated into the film I
also like tonight crawler much like in
x-men 2 they do a very good job of
showcasing his powers the advantages and
the disadvantages of his powers and I
hope to see more of him in future movies
Oscar Isaac also did well with what they
gave him as Apocalypse
he certainly spouted the I'm going to
destroy the world dialogue and the 18
variations of I'm going to destroy the
world dialogue they gave him very
forcefully it very strongly he brought a
weight to that character he brought a
menace to that character but the movie
just didn't know what to do with that
character and that's the main problem
with Apocalypse he was treated as just a
generic villain he was defeated by the
power of love essentially in the same
rubble field that Ronan the accuser was
defeated on in guardians of the galaxy I
think if he put the ending sequence of
these two movies side-by-side they'd be
shockingly similar I think Oscar Isaac
could have had a great villain turns
apocalypse but the movie didn't give him
enough to do and he just seems like a
placeholder it's a matter of fact almost
every performance in this movie is
really good but the problem is that it's
not in service to anything x-men
apocalypse doesn't bring anything new to
the table it's the same generic action
it's the same generic villain plot it's
the same generic superhero stuff that
we've seen so many times before and I'm
afraid that the x-men franchise which
has been so strong lately is starting to
slide back down again and Fox
you've already rebooted the timeline
once and you don't get another Mulligan
they made so many things right with Days
of Future past but I think that the
x-men are starting to repeat the
mistakes of the past and that might be
the real apocalypse for the x-men
franchise but what did you
did you like it did you not like it am I
being too harsh let me know in the
comments section below I love to hear
what you think also be sure to check out
some remover report every week on screen
junkies plus where we break down movies
like x-men apocalypse all the big
releases of the summer and keep you
informed about what to see in theaters
coming up I'm Dan Merrill thank you for
watching the screen junkie spoiler
review of x-men apocalypse join us next
time for the first time ever movies are
being made for comic book fans of all
ages of all tastes and instead of
letting our differences divide us I
think we should get together and
celebrate this phenomenal time that
we're living in